nous poursuivons notre reportage en
direct des lieux de la catastrophe de
nombreuses immeubles ont été entièrement
détruits et la route s'est complètement
effondrée
œuvrant parmi les décombres de
l'autoroute les gardes de la Chine
racontent de rechercher des survivants
[Musique]
la planète elle déborde de vie et en
plus elle est pleine de force bien plus
que nous tous c'est juste l'impression
qu'elle donne c'est pour
cette que les gens ne remarquent pas
sont déclin
ton avis pendant ces 5 ans il était au
Cloud il faisait quoi attends c'est à
moi que tu demandes
si j'en crois mes souvenirs
il y a 5 ans Cloud ne faisait pas partie
de cette mission
[Musique]
la rivière de la vie
cette énergie est indispensable à la
planète elle ne pourrait tout simplement
pas exister sans elle des
ombres de ses firoth auquel elles sont
connectées
on les suivants vous devriez retrouver
sa propre trace
[Musique]
à Midgar on l'a vu il est vivant comment
se fait-il qu'il soit réapparaît
après cinq ans
a-t-il fait pendant tout ce temps
ça a l'air d'être une sacrée force de la
nature
on dirait bien qu'on l'a réveillé
je me présente je suis le nouvel espoir
des teintes Elena alors ne la
sous-estimez pas
autrefois il y avait un monstre un
monstre qui pouvait lire dans les
pensées et changer d'apparence volonté
incarnez-vous peur mais aussi vos êtres
les plus chers pour vous manipuler à
votre insu
mon père
j'ai tué Tifa de mes propres mains
qui peut bien être cette femme
[Musique]